drake gave a sweet surprise to a fan who
has been battling a rare form of brain
cancer
since he was nine year old nine years
old so now 14
zalik murray got a great surprise from
the rapper
while he receives treatment at sick kids
hospital first here's drake's message
then jaleek's reaction saleek what's up
um my brother mustafa hit me the other
day
and informed me of the extremely tough
situation that you're fighting through
and uh we both thought it would be a
great thing if i got to
um send you some some love and some
admiration and some respect
um i can't imagine you know
how tough you have to be and mustafa let
me know that you're a fan of mine well
i'm a fan of you
uh i'm a fan of people with heart and i
can tell that you
that you have a lot of heart so i just
want to tell you uh stay strong
i love you and i appreciate you salique
what's up
um my brother mustafa hit me the other
day
and informed me of the extremely tough
situation that you're fighting through
and uh we both thought it would be a
great thing if i got to
um send you some some love and some
admiration and some respect
i can't imagine you know how tough you
have to be
and mustafa let me know that you're a
fan of mine well i'm a fan of you
um i'm a fan of people with heart and i
can tell
you that you have a lot of heart so i
just want to tell you uh stay strong
i love you and i appreciate you
so sweet like i love these kind of
videos yeah so it's zeke's mom was the
one that posted that yeah so her post
she says you don't even know how much
it's meant to us but most importantly
him
his strength is like no other yes he has
good days and bad days but this is
exactly what he needed to lift his
spirit to never give up you took the
time out of your day
to put a smile on a 14 year old boy's
face so yeah i love
seeing moments like this with
celebrities i love seeing moments like
this i cried when i saw it the first
time
and honestly that's so drake truly and
truly
um he loves people and he cares so much
about what people are going through and
um even though he is incredibly
successful
he's the biggest thing in the whole
world right now
music he is still very grounded and very
much the same
person he was in his teams he's the same
guy from degrassi
obviously more swag and you know more
sure of himself
but that heart has never changed no
matter
how much money how much fame how much
nonsense he goes through on a daily
basis in the music industry
um just for him to take the time to do
something like this and this is just one
of a lot of things that he does
but i'm just happy that you know the
world got to see this moment
and hopefully it inspires people to want
to
think about other people who are going
through battles and what you can do to
uplift their day because i know we're
all struggling but if we knew each
other's stories
you know we would want to do more i
think yeah
yeah yeah a lot of people a lot of
people cry kisha so mark says okay now
i'm crying
that's an awesome odds for the wind yeah
i know it says i'm not crying you are
sally's he's so happy as rap says that
it's so sweet the kid looks star shark
yeah guys this is that's so street
sweet i know he says that it's so sweet
of drake to take the time to do that
video
um uh yeah kenneth is so awesome for
drake to do that for him all the best
and yeah what i like i just like the
simplicity of it like i mean we see
like you're saying like there's a lot of
round drake right in terms of like when
he does the music video and stuff like
that like this is just drake talking to
somebody
a real connection to fans so just it's a
real simple moment with a fan
that i think yeah just reminds you the
impact that a celebrity
or singer whatever you want to call him
is can do for somebody so i think it's
just great to see it's a
it's a beautiful moment to see and yeah
it's amazing what a shocked look
zeke will have in his face yeah it's
like motivating and uplifting and i'm
sure that's just gonna
make him feel even more amazing to keep
fighting the good fight
so this all around just so feel good
oh yes i feel good for your monday yeah
i live for it i'm so happy we showed
this